right now in royal news today Harry and
Megan laid flowers and signed a
condolence book in London for the
victims of the New Zealand mass shooting
Megan is on official maternity leave and
their appearance was unscheduled
meanwhile Kate Middleton stepped out
with the Queen for a visit to London's
King's College it was the first time
that you appeared together without any
other members of the royal family and we
can reveal James Corden's connection to
the Royals our royal sorcerer reports
that Gordon's wife Julia is helping to
oversee the renovations on Harry and
Megan's 10 bedroom new home Frogmore
cottage - our city in order for really
Julia Corden is part of the design firm
Charles & Company their website shows
examples of their elegant classic style
they also supervise the remodeling of
George and Amal lavish British estate
and finally meet Prince Harry's cousin
the model Lady Kitty Spencer is the late
Princess Diana's niece she's on the
cover of Bazaar to come springy Digital
issue it's just this crazy poster energy
and excitement
[Applause]
[Music]